The difference between using
reinforcement learning for control and
using reinforcement learning without
control is basically whether or
not there's actions that
are being chosen by the learner.
And so just to make that make sense,
I'm going to swap back in
the notion of Bellman equation.
So this is the Bellman
equations without actions,
this is what we've been talking
about for the last few videos.
Do you recognize the Bellman Equation?
The value of a state is the reward
plus the discounted expected
value of the next state.
>> Yeah, I mean usually you
write that with an a in there.
>> Right, right, but I said no actions.
>> Okay.
>> We're going to
put an a back in in just a moment.
>> Okay, that'll make me feel better.
>> Certainly when we were talking
about TD we didn't really have
much of an ocean of actions.
We were really talking about sequence of
states that were being experienced and
the rewards associated with them.
And in fact the update
rule that we talked about,
this is one of the update
rules that we talked about.
Says that if we go from some state and
we get some reward and
we end up in some new state,
then what we're going to do is our new
value function estimate is going to be.
The, well, it's going to be
the same as the old one, except for
in the state that we just left.
Where we're going to move a little bit
towards the reward we got plus our
prediction, our discounted prediction
of the state that we just landed in.
So what update rule is this of the
different update rules we talked about?
>> TD(0).
>> Yeah, TD(0), factorial.
So what we need to do now is get control
back into the picture here, and so
we're going to do that now.